hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his sermon number eight joseph butler
is going to devote an entire little
section to discussing the abuses of
anger and why does he talk in those
terms because butler thinks that anger
has its legitimate purpose and functions
and scope
but it is easy to go wrong with respect
to anger and he thinks that there are
common ways in which people do this and
so he's addressing his audience and kind
of saying
look out for
these that you yourself are liable to
fall into just as much as other people
are
his first part of this discussion makes
a distinction between what he calls
passion
and peevishness we don't usually use
that word peevishness anymore so we'll
talk about what that consists in
passion we often use is like drive or
something like that but he's using it in
an older sense as well
where it means the emotion
itself going a bit too too far
in how it works and so he says
um
the first
of which occurs is what is commonly
called passion to which some people are
liable in the same way as others are to
the epilepsy or any other
sudden particular disorder this
distemper of the mind seizes them upon
the least occasion in the world and
perpetually without any real reason at
all and by means of it they are plainly
every day every waking hour of their
lives liable and in danger of running
into the most extravagant
outrages a little bit later he will use
the words
rage and fury to describe
not just the
the condition
but it's expression right so they are
liable to fall into rage
or fury over very minor occasions this
is something that is is problematic for
a person throughout their entire life
and it could be as he suggests a matter
of you know our bodily constitution
or our mind
whatever the the cause is because he
doesn't go into that this is a
susceptibility to become very angry
quite easily over minor things and a lot
of these other uh abuses of anger might
feed into it
if you are liable to this
peevishness what is peevishness so we
might describe it today as being
irritable
and expressing that in less
dramatic ways but still you know bother
some ways than rage and and fury and so
he uh tells us of a less boisterous but
not of a more innocent kind his
peevishness
which i mentioned with pity and here he
says something really interesting pity
for the people who are peevish
no
real pity to the unhappy creatures who
from their inferior station
or other circumstances and relations are
obliged to be in the way of and serve
for a
supply
of it and he tells us it's got the same
principle the same beginning points
as
passion does it's just being expressed
in a
you could say a less violent a less
boisterous way but it's still you know
misdirected anger towards other people
and butler is saying yeah i feel pity
towards all the poor bastards that are
stuck
uh enduring this from the peevish he
doesn't say he's he feels bad for the
peevish he feels bad for everybody else
who's stuck dealing with these grumpy
might be another way of expressing it
these these grumpy curmudgeonly people
who don't get into rage and fury but
they're sour they're bitter
all the time
so those are two sort of overarching
things and then he gets into a number of
more specific but still
rather general ways in which people go
wrong with anger and notice that
uh the the ones that he starts with are
cognitive they have to do with our
imagination or our inferences
that we're drawing so he says
the chief instances of abuse are and
he's going to list these off
from partiality to ourselves that means
you know thinking more about ourselves
than other people we imagine an injury
done us when there is none so this is
this is a very common way in which
people go wrong with their anger nobody
intended to do any injury to them nobody
intended to insult them to put them down
or you know cut them out of something it
just happens and then because it
happened to us
we imagine that that's what's really
happening we're projecting that idea
out there now it could be that there
actually is some sort of injury and then
we also have a tendency stemming from
the same thing we look to ourselves more
than to others
when this partiality represents it to us
greater
than it really is so you know there's an
injury but we take it as being
more significant more damaging
uh a bigger deal we might say and that's
that's on us right we're going to get
angry in proportion to
the degree that we think that somebody
is deliberately
harming us right
and then he talks about another
interesting one
here he brings up the feeling itself
right resentment
he says
we can fall into extravagant and
monstrous kind of resentment towards one
who has innocently been the occasion of
evil to us that is resentment on account
of pain or inconvenience without injury
so
pain or inconvenience takes place but
they're not doing anything to us
deliberately
and he says this is the same absurdity
as settled anger at a thing that is
inanimate like if i get angry at my tie
for not you know tying into the prop or
not or at my technology for not working
right um
there is a genuine pain or inconvenience
there right but
nobody's trying to like screw with you
nobody's doing anything deliberately to
bother you to harm you to
cause you injury and we we feel that
resentment as if it is the case right
he uses another uh similar synonymous
emotion term in the next one when the
indignation against injury and injustice
rises too high
and is beyond proportion to the
particular ill action it is exercised
upon so this is another way in which we
go wrong right we feel the indignation
which is another synonym for resentment
anger
against genuine injury and injustice so
now the person is doing something that
that could anger us
but it's out of proportion
to the offense so somebody cuts you off
in traffic and you get out your gun and
start shooting at them somebody
questions your your authority and you're
like i'm gonna crush you right these are
all
prime examples of that the notion that
if you injure me i'll hurt you back
seven fold way out of proportion right
but some people do in fact do that
and then he talks about another one that
he doesn't bring this up in terms of
you know cognition or
the
feeling
other than having resentment and he says
when pain or harm of any kind is
inflicted merely in consequence of and
to gratify that resentment though
naturally raised i think what he's
talking about here is the spillover
effect of anger
where sometimes we're angered
and we then target other people or other
things we as we say take it out on
them
we're already in a state and we start
looking for targets
he does also mention this is very
interesting one final
factor and he says it would be endless
to descend into and explain all the
peculiarities of perverseness and
wayward humor which may be traced up to
this passion i'm not going to go into
like the whole cause and effect here
he's saying because he's preaching a
sermon but he does point out one key
feature that he says
so generally belongs to and accompanies
all excess and abuse of it as to require
being mentioned what is that
this is something that other people have
noted about anger as well
it doesn't just stem from getting things
wrong
in our thinking or imagination right in
the cognitive side
it also affects how we view things
afterwards including the very anger we
feel and the actions that we take as a
result of it so he calls this a certain
determination
and resolute bent of mind
not to be convinced or set right so you
get angry at somebody and they're you
know talking to you or maybe somebody
else is talking to you and they're like
hey i you know you think that i
um did this terrible thing but actually
i you know i did do something bad but
it's not that bad so let's take the
imagining injury is greater than it is
and you're like no it really is that bad
you know you don't realize right we we
convince ourselves
that our anger is justified whether it
is or isn't and so this is sort of like
a
v you know a vice or abuse that is
accentuating the other ones he says
though it be ever so plain there's no
reason for the displeasure it was raised
merely by error misunderstanding and
what is the root of this he says in this
there is doubtless a great mixture of
pride
but
there is somewhat more which i cannot
otherwise express
than
that resentment has taken possession
of the temper and of the mind and will
not quit its
hold
and so he says this belongs to the
abuses of the passion
of anger and so you know all of these
can kind of coincide with each other if
you are subject to passion or
peevishness these are the things that
can you know produce the outbursts or
incidents of anger and so all of these
according to butler and i don't know
that he's trying to make it completely
comprehensive list he's trying to
highlight the most common
aspects of going wrong with anger all of
these are ways in which we go too far or
we get things wrong
and they can have some pretty
significant effects not only on us but
on everybody else who has to deal with
us
you